are you ready oh I'm more than ready how
did things go for you
paradise is amazing it was so fine so
emotional but ultimately all worth it
very very good so much fun told me you
were gonna own that beach did you own it
I owned the beach so much that nobody
wanted to start anything with me please
leaving the Dacians you thinking with
hannah citibank right there the drama is
just actually insane and very
entertaining and it's not like some
stupid drama you really care about it's
like oh no this is good like this is all
real this is crazy it's your good
old-fashioned dumpster fire who's the
most sought-after guy in Paradise Dylan
okay we're gonna who's the most
sought-after lady Hannah and I would say
change it to I don't care who sees that
I know that I love this girl I'm just so
happy that I found her and I can
definitely picture being with her for
the rest of my life and how serious two
things get for you in paradise you know
you'll have to watch and see
hey et make sure you tune in to Paradise
this summer I promise it's gonna be so
worth it it's a huge dumpster fire and
we all want to see it go up in flames
[Music]